Of the seven billion people on Earth, roughly six billion own a cellphone,...
...which is pretty shocking, given that only four and a half billion have access to a working toilet.
So, how are these popular gadgets changing your body and brain?
If you're looking down at your phone right now,...
...your spine angle is equivalent to that of an 8-year-old child sitting on your neck,...
...which is fairly significant considering people spend an average of 4.7 hours a day...
...looking at their phone.
This, combined with the length of time spent in front of computers,...
...has led to an increase in the prevalence of myopia or nearsightedness in North America.
In the 1970s, about one-quarter of the population had myopia, where today nearly half do.
And in some parts of Asia, 80 to 90% of the population is now nearsighted.
Your smartphone can also disrupt your sleep.
The screen emits a blue light which has been shown to alter our circadian rhythms,...
...diminishing the time spent in deep sleep,...
...which is linked to the development of diabetes, cancer and obesity.
Studies have shown that people who read on their smartphone at night...
...have a harder time falling asleep and produce less melatonin,...
...a hormone responsible for the regulation of sleep-wake cycles.
Harvard medical school advises the last two to three hours before bed be "technology-free".
So, pick up a book before bed instead.